en tout cas mon à serena williams avec
nous jusqu'à s'effacer pour serena
williams c'était sur les champs tettey
afu dans le rôle je voulais vous faire
plaisir
alors vous êtes allés avec deux trois
complices au départ et après c'est
devenu l'émeute sur les champs-elysées
au but
[Musique]
abc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
y'a pas à dire ne s'est pas du tout elle
en a qui disent oui mais elle en train
de jouer en ce moment mais c'est pas ces
crèmes
ces crèmes mais moi j'étais choqué je
savais pas que je ressemblais temps à à
serena williams est très belles toutes
les deux matches on savait que c'est mon
style c'est ray lahood
ok